hi this is vedica
i'm a research fellow at pine biotech
and i'm also studying for a master's
degree at amity university
i'm here to talk about my project where
i
these studied characteristics and tumor
and the role of tumor micro environment
in chronic lymphocytic leukemia which is
also called as cll through
transcriptomic analysis
chronic lymphocytic leukemia to begin
with is a chronic lymphoma proliferated
disorder which is characterized by an
increased production of monoclonal
pieces which are morphologically alike
and look more on the mature side but
they are immunologically dysfunctional
to perform their human immunity humoral
immunity rules by
producing antibodies and hence
they are immunologically dysfunctional
but and they also have a smudgy
appearance on the peripheral smear
so mostly genetic factors rather than
environmental factors are responsible
for the occurrence of cll but few
environmental factors such as
occupational exposure to certain
chemicals and radiation and also the use
of tobacco can lead to the occurrence of
cll
coming to the symptoms mostly patients
with cll are symptomatic at initial
presentation and a routine cbc just
casually reveals abnormal lymphocytosis
which occurs when there is a population
of greater than 5000
cells per millimeter cube of the blood
sample
approximately 5 to 10 percent of the
patients with cll symptomatic with b
symptoms such as fever unintentional
weight loss fatigue etc
so the pathogenesis of cll can be mainly
divided into two steps step one where
there occurs abnormal clonal division of
neoplastic b cells within the lymph
nodes and secondly the increased b cell
lymphocyte production which are
morphologically clonal to each other
they are released into the peripheral
blood leading to the diagnosis on cbc
b cells are very important components of
the immune system as they contain the b
cell antigen receptor also known as bcr
on which lots of molecular therapies and
precision medicine based therapies are
being designed to cure
and treat cll it's responsible for the
induction of antigen and autonomous
signaling within the cells
also as i talked about the occurrence of
uncontrolled clonal division of b cells
it can occur due to various primary
factors such as antigenic stimulation
genetic mutations and previously
existing cytogenic genetic abnormalities
but the mbl can progress to chronic
lymphocytic leukemia
by the further insult to the b cell
clones due to genetic abnormalities or
in occurrence of infections or changes
within the bone marrow micro environment
this tumor micro environment is
receiving lots of attention when it
comes to its role of within cell
signaling and the
occurrence of normal
immune responses
that's why the tumor micro environment
is also being looked at as one of the
causes and its defects can also be used
to develop therapies against cll
the tumor micro environment represents a
highly complex cellular component
including non-hemopoietic stem cells
extracellular matrix lymphocytes and
myeloid cell subpopulations these
elements call for therapy resistance by
creating an immunosuppressive
environment
that's why the question or the goal
around which the project is designed is
to understand the molecular mechanisms
behind the interdependencies of
intra-tumor heterogeneity and tumor
micro environment in cll
so for this project the data set labeled
gse161711 was obtained from the jio
website 152 samples were obtained from
37 patients and this number of samples
exceeds the number of patients because
each patient gives three types of
samples it can be broadly categorized
into two categories namely peripheral
blood and the other one was from the
lymph node
the peripheral blood sample only
contained cd19 positive cells that were
filtered and extracted and the lymph
node gave two kinds of samples namely
cd19 positive cells that were filtered
and isolated and that group was called
ln and the whole lymph node biopsies
that was ln mix where a mixture of other
kinds of cells such as t cells also
present at the lymph node and its matrix
was also obtained
which was sequenced and the reads with a
quality score of less than one were
removed
the second step was to perform a pca and
statistical analysis so the genes that
are significant and significantly
expressed could be analyzed
pca is a dimensionality reduction
reducing tool which helps us look at
multiple components of data
simultaneously
and also helps us know the variations
within express transcripts at a baseline
level
so the pci was performed using the t by
one for server pipeline and it is a very
interactive pipeline then using uh excel
we calculated the p value the p adjusted
value just to make sure that the that no
false positives were obtained when it
came to the expression of genes and log
to fold change which calculated the
differences in the quantitative
differences in the level of gene
expression for all the samples
this the third and the most interesting
part was to perform a differential gene
expression analysis which actually helps
us understand the quantification and the
significance of raw reads how they were
expressed to statistically significant
results and also helps us correlate to
their molecular pathways and the
functions of the genes so about 34 841
genes were selected for further analysis
within the lymph node subgroup a log 2
fold change filter of greater than 4 and
negative 4 was applied within the cd19
positive subgroup a log to full change
cutoff was applied as less than negative
2 or greater than 2.
the david tool was used for
us to be able to understand and
correlate the gene ids with the ensemble
ensemble gene ids which is a more
specific way of looking at genes and
also being able to correlate them with
the names and functions and the db was
used to perform gene on
gg analysis
which help us look at the pathways
associated with the genes their
functions and also the molecular
functions and biological functions of
the same
so the results were as such
firstly we got a pca plot for both the
subgroups that was the cd19 positive
subgroup where we had looked at
peripheral blood versus lymph node
samples
as you can see that the pc1 component
was 18.68
and the pc2 component was 6.68
the pc values for the lymph node group
are shown with the help of blue
triangles and we can see that they are
mostly concentrated in the second
quadrant above the x-axis
and the peripheral blood ones they are
they are uh
kind of more densely
present within the third quadrant and
are denoted by blue
red circles
so this helps us understand that there
are differences in the transcripts that
are expressed within both the
subgroups then a pca scatter plot was
obtained within the
lymph node group for cd19 positive cells
and the lymph node samples that had all
kinds of cells within the mixed group
the pc components remain the same as and
we can see that the lymph node cd19
positive cells that were obtained from
the lymph node are more concentrated in
the
second and third quadrant
on the left side of the y axis whereas
the
lymph node mixed cells are more con
concentrated in the first and fourth
quadrant away from the y-axis so this
also shows that
the transcripts that were expressed in
both the subgroups and the genes that
were significantly expressed which can
help us correlate to molecular
mechanisms like transcription gene
expression gene repair etc are different
in both the subgroups
then moving on to the statistical
analysis
uh for the lymph node subgroup after
applying the appropriate filters about
hundred and uh
1103 genes were differentially expressed
they were found to be of such
number
1101 gene were upregulated and only two
genes were down regulated within the
cd19 subgroup after we applied the
appropriate filters and filtered out
those most significantly expressed genes
about 38 387 genes were massively
differentially expressed 353 upregulated
genes and 34 down regulated genes
were found and here's a snapshot of the
david tool how it looks like and how we
are able to correlate their ensemble ids
to their gene ids and the names of the
genes
so the differential gene expression when
we were able to look at their p values
and their existed values in the log two
fold chains which all helps us
understand
uh how how quantitatively how much of
the gene was expressed uh how high or
low the gene expression was and how
significantly it was expressed with the
help of the volcanoes 2r
we drew a volcano plot
and as we can see that
that the down regulated genes are
expressed by
blue dot and the upregulated genes are
expressed with the help of red dots we
put them on a graph where the y axis
shows the
negative locked in value of the
of the p existed or the p value and the
x axis talks about the log fold change
for the cd19 subgroup we see that
certain genes were the most
significantly uh
expressed and most upregulated such as
the
ami a1a gene which is the alpha amylase
pseudogene involved in the cellular
oligosaccharide metabolic processes
and
the am em53 gene which is the
transmembrane
protein 53 which is
responsible for transmembrane
translocation of various biomolecules
and
the mrpl20 gene which is the
mitochondrial
ribosomal gene which regulates the trans
location of mitochondria the pik3cd gene
which is the phosphatidyl inositol 4-5
bisphosphonate three kinase and it is
the catalytic subunit of this uh enzyme
which is involved in b cell
proliferation development and migration
of the b cell receptor signaling and it
also helps the t cell receptors perform
their signaling functions better and
also is
responsible for a very interesting
function which is the antigen dependent
memory of b cells
also some small nuclear associated rnas
such as
lsm10 and non-coding
rnas were also found that are involved
in tumor genesis with the regulation of
gene expression and their role in
differentiation of cells by regulation
of their receptors
the most downregulated genes involved
tnrp1 and acort7 which is the acyle
coenzyme a theostery7 it is a protein
coding gene and encodes
a member of the acyl coenzyme family
which is very essential in the fatty
acid metabolism
when we talk about the pathway analysis
plot of the cd90 gene we see that the
pathways most significantly um over
expressed or most significantly
associated with the occurrence of cll
for the samples of this cd19 plus true
subgroup are the not signaling pathway
and which is associate associated with
the interactions of tumor cells with the
micro environment angiogenesis pathway
the alzheimer's disease penicillin
pathway and the hf receptor signaling
pathway and the p53 pathway
when we talk about the molecular
functions plot we see that several
molecular functions are associated with
the differences occurring within the
lymph node and peripheral blood subgroup
which is the atp dependent
activity such as the chromo domain
helicase dna binding protein 5 that
binds to the dna by a histone protein
and it regulates gene transcription
hydrolysis molec micro tubule bound
binding and catalytic activity such as
phospholipid binding signal receptor
binding by phospholipase a2 family and
other members of the cyclin-dependent
protein serine theory theonene activity
now moving on to the lymph node subgroup
we see that in the lymph node subgroup a
similar volcano plot was drawn where the
upregulated cells were
denoted with the red
circles and the blues circles were
responsible for the
denoting of the
down degraded genes we see that several
top up regulated genes such as mthfr
which is the
methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase was
over expressed to a log phone change
changes 6.68 times and is involved in
modified
increased risk of cll by increasing
homocysteine levels
the ef hand calcium binding domain 7
is
denoted by the gene afc
cab7 which
is responsible for positive regulation
of rna polymerase to dependent
transcription
the pink one gene which is the
patent-induced kinase gene encodes for
p10 and protects cells from stress
induced micro mitochondrial dysfunction
also
two to three genes were down regulated
and were observed in this group
coming to the pathway analysis plot for
this group we see that
the
pathways that are responsible for
differences within the lymph node and
the lymph node mixed
cell population
they are because of biological processes
such as signaling cell deceleration
control transformation of phases of the
cell cycle checkpoint regulation
peace and regulation growth of cells in
activated and proliferating states
interestingly
lots of immune functions such as
activation of the cd 4 plus t cells in
cell to cell signaling in antigen
presenting cells and lymphocytes was
also observed
the pathways
that were most commonly associated and
most enriched within this subgroup also
included the notch pathway
the notch pathway
is one of the most commonly observed
pathways
that acts by regulating the tumor micro
environment and also determination of
the cell faith
other pathways such as wnt signaling
pathway the jack start pathway
and
the p53 pathway was also observed which
is
shown to influence tumor genesis and
is seem to be activated by micro
environment molecules just cd40
and epitopes like that
so the principal component analysis is a
dimensionality reduction method used for
large data cells and
on the whole to summarize the project
significant differences was observed in
the tissue type such as lymph node and
peripheral blood within the cd19
expressing samples indicating micro
environment differences within the lymph
node tissue biopsy samples of most
points
and patients within the cd19 plus and
mixed
lymph node cells were variable
indicating differences in somatic
mutations and the interplay of immune
regulation
these observations of statistical
analysis identifies 1100 genes within
the lymph nodes and about 3700 genes in
the cd19 subgroup that was significantly
downregulated or upregulated it's
because of the recent advancements in
ngs and genome bytes sequencing that
have led to the understanding of
constantly mutated genes that play a
role in dna damage repair for example
tp53 chromatin modifications such as
hist1 h1e and pathway such as the notch
one signaling pathway the wnt pathway
and various other
inflammatory responses occurring in the
p cell
the functional role of myriads of
putative driving mutations have been
confirmed as gene silencing that results
in decreased cell viability and an
uncontrolled cloning expansion of
immature b cells
to conclude with the goal of this
project was to understand the up
regulated and down regulated gene
molecules associated pathways gene
products and cellular functions so that
new therapeutic targets and clinical
markets markers to predict the diagnosis
of cll patients could be understood
we noted that cll is an indolent
malignancy characterized by an increased
accumulation of cd19 positive and cd5
positive expressing cells
the tumor micro environment certainly
plays a very important role in the
prognosis of cll gene signatures
indicating the crosstalk between genetic
characteristics of cll along with those
of the immune micro environment
have been characterized by this
transcriptomic analysis
the players role in several cellular
pathways and these mutations can lead to
by a wide range of cellular consequences
such as aberrant dna repair altered pcr
signaling and an enhanced inflammatory
state in general
the critical molecular pathways such as
notch one which was the most expressed
pathway in both the subgroups and drives
chemokine signaling in the tumor micro
environment it confers disease
refractoriness and cell proliferation
along with other pathways such as the
wnt pathway and these findings provide a
fundamental information for
understanding the genes and pathways
involved in pathogenesis of the immune
micro environment that drives cll and
their role as therapeutic targets and by
biomarkers should be studied in vitro as
well as an enzyme thank you